شبيه ترامب او من وصف بالوحش الذي صنعه
رئيس الامريكي السابق قد يصارعه فعلا على
عرينه فحاكموا فلوريدا روندي سانتوس سيعلن
ترشيحه لسباق رئاسي رسميا الاسبوع المقبل
وفق ما افاد مراسل العربيه
بدا اولى خطوته رسميه لاطلاق حملته
الانتخابيه باستدعائه كبار الداعمين
الماليين الى ميامي الاسبوع المقبل كما
وقع خلال الشهور الماضيه على تدابير
لاصلاح قوانين الانتخابات وتمكين طلاب
المدارس من تحصيل قسائم يمولها دافعوا
الضرائب للتعليم الخاص فضلا عن توسيع
عقوبه الاعدام لتشمل مغتصبين الاطفال
وهكذا يضاف ديسانتس الى قائمه من المرشحين
رسميا للانتخابات تشمل جو بايدن دونالد
ترامب نكهه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات